Indonesia,...
...a beautiful chain of islands where you can see monkeys in the wild,...
...climb volcanoes, visit ancient historical sites...
...and lay around on the beach all day and night.
Consider Bali's neighboring islands of Lombok and Java,...
...the spectacular Komodo Islands and rural flowers.
You can spend 2 to 4 dollars for a double room in a hostel or guesthouse.
Accommodation prices in Bali, or the popular tourist islands of Indonesia,...
...are generally more expensive.
Street food featuring single plate meals or noodles...
...cost anywhere from 50 cents to 2 dollars.
If you want to sit down at a local restaurant, it will cost around 2 to 6 dollars per meal.
Indonesia is a budget traveler's dream.